in a society there are rules some rules
serve as laws like don't kill or steal
others function as social norms like
don't chew with your mouth open or pick
your nose in public but some are much
more nuanced some social rules aren't so
much rules but are more like
expectations and standards like knowing
how to behave in different environments
with different people like knowing who
you are which you are good at and where
you stand in various social hierarchies
and then acting accordingly like knowing
how to assess people's reactions to you
and adapting appropriately and when
someone does the wrong thing related to
one of these types of rules and acts in
a way that is oblivious and detached
from what is socially expected they're
not arrested and they are typically not
even scolded but something else
interesting happens when someone behaves
in a way that demonstrates a lack of
understanding and awareness of both
themselves in the context of society
that they are in the people observing
this individual experience a weird
phenomenon a phenomenon that's often
described as cringing a feeling of
embarrassment and pain for the other
person the videos photos music and
real-life experiences that make us coil
up and feel a tightening sensation the
instances that can make us feel horrible
for someone but kind of good about
ourselves at the same time the things
that can inherently be sad but for some
reason still tend to make us laugh
there's a weird enjoyment found in the
sensation of cringing so much so that a
huge category of humor and entertainment
is rooted in the experience of it but
why what is it about seeing someone else
do something weird wrong or embarrassing
that is so enjoyable firstly before we
answer this we should understand why we
feel the sensation in the first place
cringing is a result of an empathetic
function known as vicarious
embarrassment where an observer
empathizes with and feels embarrassment
for another person it is a response
caused by mirror neurons which are
neurons that fire when someone observes
someone else and imagines him or herself
in their shoes the cringe we feel when
watching someone breaches social
expectation and do something
embarrassing is similar to how one might
feel when seeing someone break a bone or
get a bad cut as it activates the same
part of the brain known as the pain
matrix when seeing someone else get hurt
the observer can often experience a
cringe like response as their brand
attempts to self impose the sensation in
order to effectively empathize with the
individual they are observing this
effect allows us to feel bad for others
to care about how others feel and to
function smoothly as a society we
everyone always hurting each other
however in terms of experiencing a
cringe because of someone else's
behavior it takes more than just doing
something embarrassing to be considered
cringy things like tripping in front of
a lot of people farting in the middle of
a meeting or spilling a drink on oneself
while trying to take a sip are all
certainly embarrassing but they are not
really cringey this is because they
don't contain an essential factor
something that is cringy requires a
person intentionally doing an
embarrassing action paired with a lack
of awareness that their action is in
fact even embarrassing they lack
self-awareness and furthermore they lack
awareness of the people and context
around them they have at least in this
situation what is known as a weak theory
of mind which is the psychological
ability to accurately discern one's self
from others they don't understand that
others are seeing the world differently
than them and there's no connective
tissue between how they think they are
coming off and how they are actually
coming off the person tripping in front
of a crowd did not mean or want a trip
interpreting does not suggest the lack
of self or social awareness because the
person tripping is typically aware that
it is somewhat embarrassing and responds
accordingly similarly with the other
examples making a mistake in doing
something embarrassing does not always
equal something that is indicative of
cringing perhaps it may be funny but not
always cringy examples of things that
are indicative of cringing are things
more like the singer who thinks they are
so good that they go on a national TV
talent show to perform only to turn out
being awful and ridiculed by the judges
the man who is extremely confident in
approaching a woman only to ask her out
and be harshly rejected the person who
thinks they are cool or tough in a
certain way and post something boastful
online will need to look insecure and
weak the comedian who thinks their joke
is funny but it falls flat in front of a
confused audience
no you are all all left all of these
examples contain the same principle
someone thinks of themselves in a
certain way often involving the belief
that they possess a certain skillset
then presents that sense of self in a
social context but is completely wrong
and comes off weird foolish unskilled
and/or detached from reality and when we
see this it makes us feel that cringing
sensation
I'm morbid peek into the mind of a
person who is so far out of touch that
it makes us feel pain for them but the
most fascinating question that cringing
raises is why would anyone enjoy
watching this why would the act of
observing someone flop over themselves
so miserably and so publicly be
pleasurable in life it is inevitable
that we experience things that are
awkward embarrassing and perhaps even
cringy in our own personal life we will
mess up or not be as good as we thought
we were in something we will do
something weird out of nervousness we
will learn something new and realize how
little we knew about the world only a
short time before we will feel like we
have no idea what's going on in certain
situations and that we are strange and
detached but we will hate all of this
and we will fear it and in order to
combat it we will live our life
attempting to prove to the world that we
are good composed and not weird at all
we will perform for others we will study
and examine the various social context
that we pass through building our
knowledge and understanding of how to
best perform so that we fit smoothly
into the various templates of normality
but we will know deep down that even if
we are successful in our performances
for the world we will be lying to
ourselves
that the things that society might deem
embarrassing or wrong we sometimes do
but sometimes we don't really know who
we are or how to act that we might know
what we are good at but are never really
sure of how good and if people really
like us or what we do that sometimes we
feel kind of lost like an infant being
put in the center of a corn maze and
told to find their way out and when we
watch someone else try to perform and
impress others only to end up doing
something that is so far off and weird
something that is so lacking in social
and self-awareness we realize that one's
own weirdness and uncertainty is
relatively speaking pretty normal
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder